[Musique]
avec le temps la malbouffe est devenu
véritable paratonnerre à rumeurs et
fausses nouvelles et certaines sont
particulièrement tenace gère tout ça
pour ça c'est à dire cette cloche et sur
tout ce qui est en dessous vraiment très
intrigué qu'est ce que tu dirais si je
te disais qu'il y avait en dessous de
cette cloche le hamburger mcdonald qui a
été laissé sur un comptoir pendant dix
ans dix ans dix ans de correspondance à
avoir là je veux même pas savoir c'est
vraiment comme tu vois la météo pourrie
et non mais pas de moisissures de nos
collègues qui s'y arrêtent au canada
chez lui depuis 2010 température pièce
s'est jamais les réfrigérateurs c'est
quelque chose qu'on voit souvent sur le
web ça revient tout le temps les gens où
on laisse du mec donnant sur le comptoir
et ça pourrit pas et se disent bien
c'est parce que le mec dos des produits
chimiques ou des choses comme ce qui
empêche la pourriture donc c'est une
idée vraiment qu'ils s'opposent sur le
web qui revient tout un peu tout le
temps mais quelle est l'explication
comment ça se fait que c'est surtout la
viande moss la viande qui m'intrigue que
moi c'est ce que sa poésie est
absolument venir surprenant là dedans
cela salaisons c'est une méthode de
conservation qui est connu depuis des
millénaires donc quand de la viande est
tranchée mince excès salé et qu'on
laisse à l'art libre ça sèche ça pourrit
pas une méthode de conservation donc je
dirais pas qu'on pourrait manger ça en
ce moment
et d'ailleurs en 2005 j'avais fait le
test avec quand je travaille avec le
genre métro dont j'ai repris avec donald
comme ça j'ai aussi fait un bug et moi
même avec la viande bio je l'avais
laissée sur contre les deux n'avaient
pas pour rire donc c'est vraiment pas
une propriété qui spéciale avec le
mcdonald's viande le farceur mais j'ai
aussi pris un bain de mcdonald's je les
lis dans un sac hermétique et leur ça
pourrit complètement c'est absolument
dégueulasse
une question d'humidité donc quand les
ce soir le comptoir ça ça sèche
rapidement il n'y a aucune humidité pour
permettre à la mode sur de prendre
prendre place dans la nourriture mais
quand on met ça dans un sac hermétique
ça pourri comme n'importe quel autre
nourriture c'est pas la preuve qu'il ya
de produits chimiques nourriture je
pensais jamais être précisées mais je
note c'est que ça brûle à sa plus simple
expression au pot de fromage peu de
l'étude n'ont ni ketchup et moutarde
je reviens toutes ces rumeurs qui
circulent on l'a vu encore récemment nos
sur internet à propos de ce genre
d'expérience là qu'est ce que ça nous
dit sur les idées préconçues qu'on peut
avoir c'est justement ce que on a
tendance en tant qu'être humain un trou
déconnexion des choses qui n'ont
peut-être pas vraiment rapport donc avec
le mc donald's bien des gens se disent
bon le mcdonald's ces industriels comme
nourriture et puis là on remarque que ça
pourrit pas et ont dû batailler au cosby
mais ce n'est pas nécessairement le cas
donc c'est pas de la bonne science de
bonne science c'est vraiment de voir
comparer ces situations là d'autres
situations similaires donc il n'y a pas
de lien entre la nature artificielle ou
industriels du midi mcdonald's et la
police que je me devais savoir vraiment
au sérieux tout ce que tu dis mais bon
c'est ça de bon appétit
[Musique]